Y luego, finalmente, la salud.
Los combustibles fósiles son una especie de cigarrillo global.
Y, en mi opinión, el carbón es como un cigarrillo sin filtro.
Al igual que con los cigarrillos, ¿cuándo es el mejor momento de dejarlos?
Público: Ahora.
TZ: ¡Ahora! No cuando tengamos cáncer de pulmón.
Yo sé que hay gente que abandona la razón e ignora la evidencia.
Hasta que empiezan a sufrir.
(Risas)
Sí, abandonan la razón e ignoran la evidencia,
pero a la larga, el sufrimiento los obliga a cambiar, inevitablemente.
En lugar de eso, usemos nuestro neocórtex, el cerebro recientemente evolucionado,
para salvar a los Ancianos, unas de las criaturas más antiguas.
Y apliquemos la ciencia para aprovechar la energía
que ha alimentado a los Ancianos durante millones de años:
el sol.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)